the nation's largest labor union is
urging social media companies to crack
down on a new craze which dares students
to vandalize schools there is a viral
challenge asking kids to destroy
in-still school property and then share
the video online jamie yukis is
following this story for us and joins us
right now jamie good morning
good morning nate tick tock and other
social media challenges of course are
nothing new in the past we've seen money
raised for charity and in the pandemic
we saw all those families get creative
with dance moves but schools say these
latest pranks are destructive and
dangerous
what the [ __ ] is going on bro
hundreds of soap dispensers paper towel
dispensers toilet paper rolls have been
ripped off of walls food and other items
smeared
across walls and floors and stalls
clarksville montgomery county schools
chief communications officer anthony
johnson says recent vandalism has caused
roughly 20 thousand dollars in damages
at more than a dozen schools in the
tennessee district
both of our toilet seats the destruction
johnson says is linked to a nationwide
viral challenge called devious licks
encouraging kids to destroy or steal
school property and post it online
addison goldberg and lilly lambert
attend one of the vandalized middle
schools why does something like that
gain popularity it's just wanting the
attention whether it be positive or
negative they want the attention because
they either aren't getting
some at home or they just want it
because they feel insecure about
themselves now some schools worry that
the trend may affect personnel with the
latest rumored viral challenge slap a
teacher
this new challenge is assault are you
concerned
certainly assaulting any employee is a
zero tolerance offense fearing the worst
the national education association sent
a letter to facebook tick tock and
twitter demanding the tech giants take
action to regulate lies and fix your
algorithms to put public safety over
profits becky pringle is president of
the association
what i we are saying to the social media
companies is that we would want we want
to work with them
to ensure that they not only see it but
they respond to it in a statement to cbs
news a tick tock spokesperson said the
alleged challenge would violate our
policies and we would aggressively
remove such content but the reality is
that we have not found related content
on our platform
now we did reach out to facebook and to
twitter but have not heard back yet the
clarksville montgomery county school
district told us more than six thousand
dollars in fines have been paid so far
and according to the school district's
policy a student's report card
transcript and diploma can be held until
the student's family pays off those
damages nate excuse me and rightfully so
jamie thank you so much i'm raising a 17
year old 15 year old and an 11 year old
and you have to ask these questions
and also challenge them don't you dare
do something like this
i'm heartened to hear that the the slap
a teacher part of it is not yet taking
off we saw that one video but the uh
twitter saying it or tick tock saying
it's not widespread yet but the rest of
it the bathroom stuff is the most
knuckleheaded thing i've ever seen
that's your bathroom you go to that
school what are you doing but you know
what tony we don't want it to become
widespread that's why the minute it
comes up they'd ought to be taken down i
agree and the students should be banned
from the
should be banned from the platform
that's just not okay they can do
something about that yes for parents
that don't understand this this is like
when we used to get dared to do
something double their triple dog dare
you now it's in the palm of their hand
and these kids they are influenced and
they're shooting video of themselves
doing it absolutely like i said toilet
paper people's houses and we thought
that was extreme all the good old days
you wouldn't take pictures of it